this video is made possible by trends
trends is the ultimate knowledge hub
from the hustle trends is a networking
community for entrepreneurs and budding
entrepreneurs it's a place where you can
connect
and even workshop with investors and
founders who can share valuable insights
to help get your
ideas off the ground trends brings
together expert knowledge
data science and investigative
journalism to track new industries and
likely trends
do you remember our video about the
surprising success of a2 milk that
outstripped tech companies in profits in
2019. well
over on trends you can find in-depth
trends analysis on the alternative milk
industry as well as detailed reports on
loads of niche markets that could really
help you to capitalize on your own ideas
or maybe you're stuck for ideas dive
into trends exclusive research with
intriguing topics to help inspire like
the 30 companies defining the future of
media and pop culture or data
on thousands of successful kickstarter
projects we also like the live weekly
lectures from founders who give
practical tips about everything from
internet security to branding to getting
the most out of youtube hey you're never
too old to learn something new best of
all
right now you can get your first seven
days for just one dollar go to trends
dot co
slash vp for your one dollar seven day
trial now let's see what grant is
talking about today
[Applause]
[Music]
so my friends at visualpolitik today we
are going to talk about a thorny issue
because we are going to focus on the
company where visualpolitik is hosted
and one which owns the platform both you
and i are using right now we are talking
about
[Music]
alphabet and you'll see
but wait a minute grant alphabet you're
on youtube well yes
we are on youtube but youtube is a part
of google and in turn
google is the main subsidiary of the
conglomerate alphabet and that means
that we're not just talking about
youtube but we're also talking about
google maps google earth android google
drive and a long list
of other things you see my friends the
internet is big
and diverse but most of what you find on
here comes under the umbrella
all or is dependent on five major
players
alphabet i.e google facebook amazon
apple and microsoft these five large
companies are also called
annoyingly gafam or more properly
big tech and so you'll say so what's the
problem graham for example if it weren't
for a platform as big as youtube
visualpolitik wouldn't exist nor would
almost any of the channels that you all
like so much and which have started with
some friends recording videos
[Music]
yes we could have a website but who
would know about us without a search
engine like google we would have had to
spend
thousands of dollars in advertising just
to reach you and that's unthinkable
for almost any youtuber however there is
a risk
i'll give you an example today the
google search engine has more than
80 of the market worldwide there are
very few countries where google is not
the dominant search engine
russia where it competes with yandex and
china where
it is obviously banned it's china after
all
in the rest of the world google is the
main search engine and when i say
main i mean that in countries as
widespread in spain india and brazil
more than 90 of searches are made
through google in other words we could
talk about the existence of a google
monopoly
on searches the name of the company even
means to search
i'll just google it and you're probably
thinking but is this really a problem
well it depends on how you look at it on
the one hand google has earned its
position by providing a fantastic
service
the question now is could a company
emerge that would be able
to compete with them and many of you
will think what does it matter which
search engine you use
if you only use them for well
for everything the search engine is the
first thing we use before entering a
website that is
if something does not appear in the
first search results of a google search
then that thing basically doesn't exist
this means google has a lot of power
in theory this power isn't necessarily
bad but sometimes it can have
consequences
like this
antitrust eu commission finds google
2.42 billion euro for abusing dominance
as search engine by giving a legal
advantage to own comparison shopping
service
eu commission this is just one of the
many fines that the european commission
has imposed on google for what they call
abusing its market position as of today
google is appealing these fines in court
none of these cases has an easy answer
europe says google is abusing its market
position google
says that both its search engine and its
android operating system
are theirs it is logical that if you
enter a store the owner wants to promote
their product
over any others for whatever reason as
you can see we are talking about a
debate where even the team here at
visualpolitik
don't really have a clear opinion and i
know what many of you are probably
thinking
what if this was a strategy by europe to
punish an american company well the
truth is that these legal battles are
not limited to europe
check this out
u.s justice department and 11 states
accuse google of antitrust violations
the lawsuit accuses google of using its
enormous size to illegally monopolize
the market for search generated
advertising
nbc news as you can see this is a charge
very similar to those that europe has
already presented and the judicial
process will most likely go on for years
again we are talking about a debate
where there is no easy answer before
going any further we have to say that
google is not the only company facing
anti-trust battles apple
facebook and amazon are going through
very similar processes but in this video
we are going to focus on the alphabet
group that is to say
we're going to focus on google so if the
lights go out and this video cuts off
halfway through
you know why
[Music]
today the question we're asking is so
where does this legal battle come from
to what extent are we talking about
economic reasons or simple political
interests how does anti-monopoly
legislation work we're going to answer
all of these questions but first
let's look at some history
the great dilemma of capitalism
capitalism is an economic system that is
based on you being able to start a
business and if you provide a good
service to people
you will do well and if you give
extraordinarily good service you can
become practically the only provider
of this service
this really doesn't happen as often as
people think in fact most of the
monopolies that exist in the world are
state-generated monopolies
in other words most of the monopolies in
the world are owned by public
companies for example in spain renfie
has a monopoly on trains
some postal services are a state
monopoly in the united states
but there are also monopolies that arise
from the free market system
itself and this collides with another
basic principle
of our beloved capitalism competition
that is as long as there are several
companies competing in a field products
will usually improve in quality
and reduce in price if one company is
not offering quality and good value
customers will go to another if a
company is big enough it can buy off its
potential competitors
for example when facebook bought
instagram it ended up with one of its
biggest competitors
is this good or bad for the market there
are valid opinions from every point on
the spectrum and this is when we talk
about antitrust laws and abuse of a
dominant possession an example of this
would be microsoft
if you remember back in the 1990s
microsoft had a monopoly on operating
systems
90 of personal computers around the
world used windows so the question was
not between microsoft or apple but
between windows 95 or windows 98
and then this happened
[Music]
[Applause]
justice department files anti-trust suit
against microsoft for
unlawfully monopolizing computer
software markets
justice.gov this 1998 lawsuit became
bill gates's nightmare he was driven so
crazy by this that many years later he
would invent a covert 19 vaccine just so
he could track his
all that is a joke what actually
happened is the department of justice
accused microsoft
of unfair competition illegal
exclusivity clauses and also of abusing
its dominant position by including its
own internet explorer browser in the
windows operating system and i think we
can all agree
that forcing us to use internet explorer
was a crime the result however
was this
microsoft ordered to split into two
companies the guardian in fact
microsoft had to split into two one
company in charge of operating systems
and the other in charge of software
however microsoft appealed and reached a
less drastic but still quite
painful agreement it accepted that
competing companies would have access to
its systems and application programming
interfaces for the following
five years
[Music]
these days 20 years after that lawsuit
microsoft no longer has a monopoly on
operating systems
apple has gained more market share than
it had before and there are even people
who use their cell phones more than
computers so operating systems like
android are coming into play in other
words
microsoft is still a very competitive
company but it no longer
has a monopoly
and here comes the big question that
will blow your mind would this have
happened if it wasn't for government
intervention or was there always room
for companies to outshine
microsoft i'll leave that for you to
reflect on but now
let's get back to something we can
answer what are they accusing google of
what are the charges they are bringing
to accuse google of monopolistic
practices
let's take a look at that right now
don't be evil as you all know google is
one of those companies created by an
immigrant sergey brin is one of the
co-founders of google with larry page
brynn is a russian oracle
1995 these two students from stanford
devised the basic algorithm of what
would later become
three years later they already had
investors a company incorporated under
the
clever name google incorporated and even
their own headquarters which
a garage that by the way was owned by
the person who would later become the
ceo
of youtube at that time the internet was
just beginning it only had
200 million users worldwide even so
there were already search engines like
yahoo yandex and alta vista plus a long
list of others that
everyone's forgotten many of them even
advertised on tv
how'd you find this place
[Music]
yahoo
although there was not yet a clear
business model investors were convinced
that the internet was the future so the
race to adapt
was wild now the next time you think
you've made the biggest mistake of your
life
remember excite
you probably don't even know what i'm
talking about do you well
in the late 90s excite was one of the
most important portals on the internet
with its own search engine an email
service
and a lot more in 1999
paige and brynn wanted to sell their
fledgling google to excite for the grand
sum of
wait for it 750 000
that's right 750 thousand dollars it
wasn't even worth a million
however excite declined the offer and
they weren't the only ones
yahoo did exactly the same thing
[Music]
both companies knew that google's
algorithm offered slightly better
results than theirs
but with the algorithms they already had
they weren't doing so badly
why change something that already works
three years later excite
was bankrupt to fully understand this
you have to think about the disruption
that google represented at that time
google prioritizes results based on what
matters to the user this may seem
obvious today
but at that time search engines
prioritize results based on their own
interests
but not only that google was the only
search engine designed to do
just that search yahoo and many others
tried to offer an
all-in-one for you to stay on their
website news weather
and even games in other words google
offered a much better product
for users and users rewarded google with
their trust
in fact the slogan that summarizes the
philosophy of this company and
can be seen in all its offices is
menacingly
don't be evil
[Music]
in other words don't be evil and don't
become one of those big and soulless
evil companies in fact today google is
one of the companies that treats his
employees best
if you want to know what a really fancy
breakfast is make friends with someone
who works at google you will never see a
bigger and better
free buffet in your life so i'm told
anyway knowing it
google wants to be friends with me and
the truth is that this formula has
worked for them
until this point when google went public
in 2004 its shares were worth
85 it was already a company comparable
to ford with a market capitalization of
23 billion dollars well these days we're
talking
about a trillion dollars so what did
google do to grow so much
as you know nowadays google is a
conglomerate that offers all kinds of
services it has the most used browser in
the world
cloud services and of course
this series
google buys youtube for 1.65 billion
dollars
nbc news in short google has totally
changed how we use the internet
and let's be clear has changed it for
the better without looking too far
youtube has achieved what no public
television station has ever achieved the
distribution of educational and
informative content to millions of
people look google i said it
please don't demonetize our channel and
i know what you're all thinking of
course graham
it's normal to think that way google has
literally changed our life
don't worry about it and if you think
that let's see what the problem is with
the fact that google
is just so big
[Music]
the abuse of power you don't become a
trillion dollar company without making
enemies one of the first was none other
than
the country france when google books
came out the french government refused
to let a foreign company digitize its
cultural heritage
so france put pressure on brussels to
create a state version of google books
europe
the truth is that this product has ended
up being
a bit of a disaster other enemies of
google are the traditional companies
whose business model
gets upset by the internet an example of
this is the case of google news against
spanish media in 2004 the spanish
government passed a law by which portals
such as google news had to pay a fee to
the media in order to show clips of the
news
which is what google news does what
happened next will not surprise you
google shut down news site in spain over
copyright fees
reuters but it must be recognized there
are also cases where legitimate
criticism can be made of google there
are cases where we could perhaps speak
of a certain
unfair advantage one of these cases is
google maps google created its mapping
service in 2005
but of course before that time there
were already lots of companies offering
maps
on the internet if you had a website and
you wanted to insert a map with your
address
you could hire one of these companies
and this obviously
had a cost
but then google came along and they did
it for free
as a consequence many digital mapping
companies were automatically
bankrupt years later without any
competitors left standing
google maps became a paid service that
is
using google maps at home is free but
using the google maps api for a large
website
does incur a charge in this matter the
french company bought in cartographies
even sued google maps in the tribunal
the commerce they accused the tech
company of what is known as
dumping that is taking advantage of the
fact that you are a very big company to
set very low prices for a while
in order to raise your competitors to
the ground we also have the case
of android google bought android inc in
2005.
today 7 out of 10 mobile devices in the
world use android
[Music]
in this market google is the king and
this means that it can use
all these devices to promote to the rest
of its services that is
you buy an android phone and have the
google search engine on the main
screen chrome is the default browser and
google play installed by default someone
who has another application store would
have a hard time competing with google
simply because
they have such a hold on the market with
android and this
was precisely the reason for the fine of
more than four billion dollars that the
european commission imposed on google
in 2018. something similar happens with
google shopping if you search for a
product on google the first strip that
appears are the products that google
itself
sells and that's why both europe and the
united states are putting so many
demands on this company
in fact the us department of justice's
lawsuit against google is the largest in
the industry since the microsoft case in
1998.
what's more if the case against google
is successful it will also have direct
consequences for other big tech
companies
amazon facebook and apple what could
happen if google loses the easiest thing
would be to find it as the european
commission did but
in this case the question is to what
extent does a fine
really affect a company as gigantically
rich
as google at the other extreme we have
the proposals like that
of us senator elizabeth warren
[Music]
elizabeth warren says she wants to break
up amazon google
and facebook the verge what elizabeth
warren proposes to do
is to separate google into several
different companies it wouldn't be the
first time that something like this has
happened the great precedent is a t
the giant telecommunications company in
the united states in
1984 it was forced to split into several
small companies known as the big
brothers that's another joke it was
called the baby bells
so what's the problem the problem is
that these measures violate property
rights
but that's not all most likely the
companies that would emerge from
google's atomization would end up being
monopolies in their respective niches
so the most likely option is the united
states would force google to share its
platform and some of its algorithms with
competitors
and here we come back to the question
with which we started this whole video
is it really so impossible to compete
with google even if you have a better
service
as you can imagine google says no
their lawyers argue that if alphabet
companies have got where they are it's
only because they are better and it is
likely that we will have the answer
[Music]
soon
tech companies including spotify and the
maker of fortnite
seek to reform app stores marketwatch it
is very likely that several tech
companies will end up joining together
to create their own
google play competitor these companies
complain about the commissions they have
to pay to be in the app stores and maybe
they'll come up with their own
alternative
at that point we'll see how easy or
difficult it is to compete in a segment
as momentous as mobile applications
in the meantime here are a couple of
questions for you do you think that the
european fans on google
are effective do they really encourage
competition and creativity or is it
really google's bad luck that no one has
found the formula to compete with
it's search engine in short why do
almost all of us
use google and we're not looking for
filthy answers i know why some of you
use google you can leave your answers
in the comments as always we really hope
you enjoyed this video please hit like
if you did and don't forget to subscribe
for brand new videos
don't forget to check out our friends
too at the reconsider media podcast they
provided the vocals in this episode that
weren't my dulcet tools
finally this channel is possible because
of patreon and our patrons on that
platform
please consider joining them and
supporting our mission of providing
independent political coverage and
as always i'll see you next time and if
you want to learn more about politics
and hear even more of my lovely voice
you can join us at reconsider media we
have a podcast at reconsider media.com
podcast see you there